hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I am also
Jerry so today we're checking out the
trailer YouTube channel inspiration here
today Smosh the movie oh boy all right
they got an official trailer just
recently released I'm interested because
they are [ __ ] funny they are some
funny ass guys they have earned the
level of success and I'm almost right up
there with them you know I'm just as
creative as them with my reactions
mm-hmm
pg-13 though I would go for a hard seize
this video it's gonna remind her how
much of a loser I used to be
let's get the video removed from YouTube
it's mr. YouTube available to CSP
where's the maker he'll go Steve YouTube
place of any chips TV you've got video
removed from your website your best bet
is to change the video from really cool
videos yeah I know exactly who you are
kidding me no idea
thank you so much for watching really we
can't wait for you guys to watch the
full movie the meter
wait is that directed by Alex winter
like who played Bill and Bill and Ted
Alex winter that would be very
interesting because all I was thinking
was Bill and - yeah yeah yeah
did you know directed the direct the guy
who played Bill is [ __ ] doing that is
awesome okay yes some of the jokes look
very hit and miss I wasn't quite with
this trailer until Michael Ian Black
opened up the portal and they went into
M tube and I was like oh this looks kind
of this looks actually fun and wacky
yeah when they went when I started
getting more interesting when they were
like Steve YouTube that was funny
I was like alright that's cool a movie
taking place at YouTube that's
interesting
and then when they it's about them going
into YouTube videos I thought that was
such a clever take like it is Bill and
Ted but YouTube world that is so [ __ ]
cool this is kind of like the idea we
pitched when we were at the YouTube
campus that one day yeah I know it's
gonna be exciting is you're gonna see
cameos from other youtubers it's awesome
that you see jenna Marbles in the
trailer yeah she's so [ __ ] hot man oh
oh you know they come from YouTube and
they're honoring that you know they're
not like trying to do like hey we're not
we're trying to be like a film now you
know they're like no we know we're from
the YouTube world so they're honoring
that that is so they're neat integrating
it directly into the DNA of the story
[ __ ] love the idea I thought of
movies I could take place in the YouTube
world but never that creative that is a
fun way to go about it this trailer was
really hidden miss for me but that was
my favorite stuff was like yeah that
sort of wackiness because some of the
slapstick and some of the early jokes
there's a place for slapstick humor
that's fine but some of the jokes seem
like really really low route like yeah
like yes fine it's just that it's not
all of it wasn't my humor so yeah I mean
Smosh is humor
can be that way I'm pretty sure it's
just the trailer because you know they
write some really funny [ __ ] skits
okay so if they have some hilarious
sketches out there but they're only
taking lines from the sketch because I'm
pretty sure the scenes will play out
like a miniature sketch comedy always
you know you need context you know and
trio just don't give you contact how
they look for like those one lines you
know like and I usually don't laugh at
those anyway so so Smosh congratulations
guys done Jeff I know you guys are huge
fans of this channel so thank you for
your support on our channel if you guys
are new to the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects you can check out
Jerry's playlist on this channel
mmm reason this is Jerry and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine cuz if we get enough followers
we can get product I spent people Mason
husky before I do the shout out I just
wanna say anyone with a name Mason you
can always trust up hey man I've been
watching you for a while and [ __ ]
funny and I would love to get a shout
out Mason dude listen man there's no
photos of you on your Facebook you're a
very mysterious man so Mason sounds
let's be honest sounds like he's a P
file Oh No yeah don't just accuse
somebody on that he sounds like he's P
file that's up why would you abbreviate
it cuz it makes sense why would you need
to abbreviate that word no I get file no
it makes sense but but that it doesn't
need a cool abbreviation is Mason the P
file his name is happy has he stands for
snatching boys
no don't how how did you arrive me devil
is snatching boys pitha in what language
English